oi gente boa tarde é tudo bem eu começa
então a minha conversa com uma pergunta
que é pra cada um de vocês pensaram
longo da nossa conversa quem sabe demora
um pouco mais de tempo pra vocês
respondem mais qual é o sonho de vocês
foi um pouco com essa pergunta que a
jornada começou esta jornada em busca de
novas aprendizagens eu vou contar pra
vocês um pouco sobre a história do
coletivo educação que começou em 2011 e
agora 15 dias a gente acabou de lançar o
livro então é muito gostoso poder falar
de um sonho que se realizam
aqui nós temos então o coletivo ele
começou numa tarde de sábado em
fevereiro de 2012
oshima que é esse de camisa verde ele é
um engenheiro de formação ele deu aula
muito tempo e muito inquieto com a
educação de hoje ele começou a perguntar
para os seus alunos ele dava aula de
sustentabilidade quem sabia por que
estava lá na aula dele e ele conta que
ao longo de muitos anos ele conseguiu
preencher uma mão ele tem uma filha de
quatro anos e também estava nessa busca
por uma educação diferente para ela
sou eu aí do lado do chimarrão eu vim da
psicologia do trabalho com inovação e me
interessa muito pela criatividade e eu
acredito que a educação ela deve de
alguma maneira fomentar os nossos sonhos
as nossas realizações como é que a gente
faz para ser uma potência de nós mesmos
e acho que foi um pouco isso que me
trouxe aqui me trouxe do coletivo a
carla ela tem dois filhos a dorinha de 4
anos que estava iniciando a educação
nela eo bruno com 19 que tinha acabado
de sair da escola e tinha acabado de
comprar para ela que ele não iria entrar
na faculdade então ela tinha um dilema
dupla aí o andré gravatá 23 anos
jornalista hoje neste momento na índia
determinou o livro e decidiu descansar
na índia para escrever outro livro o
filme e bom ele foi o quarto elemento do
coletivo
nos juntamos e a gente definir o que a
gente queria escrever um livro sobre uma
jornada pelo mundo afora em busca em
busca de escolas inovadoras inspiradoras
que pudessem trazer novas respostas e
ares preços para uma educação que já tá
aí
essas foram então as nossas premissas a
gente sabia desde o ponto
o que a gente queria três pontos o
primeiro era que esse livro inspirasse
mais inquietos jovens curiosos e
professores educadores e empreendedores
o segundo é que a gente queria uma maior
diversidade possível de escolas e as
escolas entre aspas é porque no final a
gente acabou indo buscar algumas
universidades alguns entre os que vão
mostrar rapidamente pra vocês
o terceiro ponto essa disseminação desse
conhecimento que a gente buscou um free
download é um baixar livre desse livro
então depois você entre no site quem se
interessar pode ter acesso ao livro na
íntegra
e aí como é que aconteceu tudo isso a
gente tinha r$0 e muitos sonhos que a
gente tinha um tempo pra fazer com que
essa jornada acontecesse tudo começou a
gente colocou um projetinho debaixo do
braço e saiu batendo na porta de um
monte de pessoas para tentar entender é
se elas poderiam nos ajudar
eis então que a plataforma no catarse
foi uma grande solução essa é uma
plataforma de financiamento coletivo
depois quem quiser posso contar um
pouquinho mais mas aqui graças a 566
pessoas apoiadores a gente conseguiu
arrecadar 56 mil reais e foi aí então
que a gente já tinha na verdade começou
a jornada mas que a gente se sentir
ainda mais empoderado pra continuar por
essa jornada
o coletivo é o nosso blog então se você
entrar no blog no blog ele está agora em
com essa carinha aí ele foi na verdade
um ponto de contato pra gente porque em
julho andré decidiu que ele embarcar sem
o catarse a gente ainda não tinha feito
catar neste momento e ele iria viajar em
julho depois em agosto já tinha mudado
as minhas férias eu logo irá embarcar ia
acabar em outubro a gente precisava de
um ponto de contato de um diário de
bordo para contar um pouco das nossas
histórias e foi muito interessante
porque foi exatamente aqui que a gente
começou a contar da nossa história para
o mundo e várias pessoas poderão
acompanhar a gente acabou também criaram
uma página de facebook então essa foi a
nossa forma de che de comunicar um pouco
que a gente estava fazendo aqui tem um
mapa da nossa jornada então ao todo a
gente visitou 13 espaços inicialmente
livro se chamava volta ao mundo em 12
escolas mas graças ao catar se a gente
conseguiu visitar mais uma que foi uma
13ª
a gente passou por nove países ea gente
conversou com 300 pessoas
legal contra duas coisas a primeira é
que não sei se eu mencionei no começo
mas nenhum de nós se formou em educação
nem nenhum de nós era um especialista no
tema na verdade o nosso embarque foi
como um curioso no tema
a gente tinha uma intenção de entender
um pouco a educação de fora de que não
muito conhece então como leigo ea nossa
conversa foi com pais com alunos com
professores com os alunos para que eles
pudessem contar pra gente um pouco da
realidade dessa história isso foi muito
legal porque a gente acabou executando
diversas mas aí depois que fui convidada
por preços até decidir fazer um
exercício que foi na sala de aula sempre
é o ponto crítico ponto inicial desse
debate de uma nova educação então deixa
eu pegar um pouco a foto dessas escolas
nessas iniciativas que a gente visitou
pra ver como é que elas são e então esse
o embarque que eu convido vocês a
fazerem comigo pra que a gente olhe
rapidamente infelizmente não vou poder
parar e contar de uma de cada uma delas
por causa do tempo
mas amorim em são paulo essa é uma sala
que tem três séries juntos amorim foi
inspirada na escola da ponte do pacheco
lá em portugal um salão que eles estão
organizados a aprender o que eles querem
por roteiros a escola experimental lá na
argentina muito pautada em arte e na
meditação na respiração e no silêncio
vão observando também essas salas de
aulas que a gente está contando aqui que
estão mostrando pra vocês
na índia lá no riverside então a gente
tem e que elas não são as únicas nem tão
por exemplo essa não é a única sala
universal e logicamente mas aqui a
professora convidou os alunos a
conversar em um pavilhão e se a gente
observar no cantinho os alunos eles
estão dando aula junto com os
professores que é um hábito muito comum
nessa escola
a política em são paulo aqui é uma
assembléia que estão definindo algumas
regras pais alunos e seu filhinho da
carol que a diretora do colégio na
schumacker uma escola faltar em
sustentabilidade
vivi muito a comunidade esse é uma após
a aula é a discussão ela se estendeu e
acabou indo para esse espaço seja campo
limpo esse é voltado para jovens e
adultos que querem se reinserir no meio
são elas uma escola que quase que ajudem
esses jovens a repensarem seus sonhos a
sonharem novamente risco em bari quase
inteira feita de bambu super sustentável
ea sustentabilidade ela acaba sendo
transversal a todas as aulas e eles
vivem essa sustentabilidade pelos cinco
sentidos resto lan
aqui a gente aprende que é legal se
aprender que a gente pode aprender
brincando ela quase inteira pautada em
jogos
então eles têm os desafios os
professores fazem vários quests que eles
chamam é que são esses desafios e aí
assim eles vão aprendendo brincando de
uma maneira bastante 30 transdisciplinar
assim como o sistema de bilhete no sítio
aqui onde estima hoje em dia então no
meio da jornada última parou aqui não
saiu mas ele só volta ano que vem está
fazendo mestrado no sistema beneficia de
tinto e um tema que até mim que é uma
escola pautada no empreendedorismo
ela se iniciou na finlândia nós fomos lá
na espanha e conversar com alguns alunos
porque ele tem uma outra unidade e essa
é a sala de aula dos alunos da espanha a
índia
lá no taj mahal ipp muito voltado para o
autoconhecimento é um planejamento para
aqueles que saem da escola ainda não
estão prontos para a universidade é um
ano para eles pensarem no seu projecto
de vida e pensar em também como é que
eles podem ser empreendedores sociais e
aqui tem escola ou na verdade o centro
popular de cultura do tião rocha e esse
é um menino que está aprendendo a
escrever com um biscoito escrevido eles
colocam as letras e assim eles vão
aprendendo e vão se alfabetizando eu
falo então rapidamente do novo start foi
onde eu parei eu falo ou não estar
porque é um centro de aprendizagem alto
direcionado
quando cheguei eu vi logo essa frase
aprender é natural escola é opcional e
aí o lanço meu deus mas escola opcional
onde eles vão então o que eles estão
fazendo
e aqui se abre um todo o universo de ram
disco em que a dis escolarização que o
ensino domiciliar é quase que um clube
de aprendizagem onde estão lá porque
eles querem aprender aquilo que eles
escolheram e não aquilo que foi imposto
eu vou logo para mim
park e aproveitar meus últimos cinco
minutos pra contar pra vocês um pouco
dessa jornada
eu comecei perguntando pra vocês dos
sonhos e logo depois trouxe então as
salas de aula
eu acho que o primeiro ponto que a gente
logo pode ver é que eu confesso que me
surpreendi que a sala de aula ela ela é
só uma das possibilidades que a gente
tem a gente tem visto isso hoje ao longo
dos dias em várias outras iniciativas
que a gente vê que já existem
a sala de aula ela é um ponto onde as
pessoas elas podem começar as interessa
por uma educação mas a gente vê que a
educação é muito mais ampla que isso a
gente aprendeu ao longo dessa jornada
que a educação é para cultivar ela é
para criar é para transformar ela para
instigar as pessoas a buscarem aquilo
que faz sentido para elas
a gente entendeu ea gente investigou
espaços que estão abertos ao erro como a
gente tem visto ao longo do dia de hoje
eo erro é proporcionar com que não isso
seja um fracasso mas que isso seja uma
oportunidade para o novo e por não saber
muitas vezes não saber te minha gente eu
acho que aí tem uma experiência minha na
hora que a gente se coloca como leiga no
assunto
muitas vezes a gente fica pensando nossa
mas será que sou eu que tenho de falar
sobre isso
será que sou eu que vou trazer algumas
respostas será que sou eu que de fato
vou conseguir levar a inovação ou
proporcionar algumas iniciativas
inovadoras e inspirador e inspiradoras
pelo mundo afora e aí o que a gente vê
que inovação inspiração na educação é
ser humano né são pessoas é recurso
humano são pessoas que têm a coragem de
simplesmente transcender aquilo que tá
ali posto
são pessoas que estão refletindo são
pessoas que aceitam não saber que se
colocam ao lado de um aluno para
construir com ele e pra aprender junto
com ele e que a aceitam a possibilidade
desse aluno ensinar por um outro aluno e
que assente por um adulto ou então um
pai que também está disposto a
transformar a comunidade da escola
porque muitas vezes ele vai trazer uma
solução que quem está ali no dia a dia e
está viciado naquela rotina não
conseguem enxergar eu esse projeto ele
por seu nou uma 14ª escola eu acho que
foi a própria jornada em si eu confesso
que eu entrei com um sonho eo sonho meio
intangível nela é sempre meio distante a
gente olha e não sabe muito bem para
onde ele vai
e eu saí com uma nova roupagem eu acho
que a minha casca ela mudou isso ela
ainda está em transformação por que tudo
isso foi tão recente em outubro a gente
lançou esse livro e eu tô entendendo que
pra gente pensar uma nova educação a
gente tem que sair do lugar-comum lugar
do conhecido ea gente tem que se colocar
um outro lugar que é de perguntar muito
mais do que responder
as pessoas perguntavam pra gente aí qual
é o resultado que vocês esperam e eu
confesso que a gente falava nossa eu não
sei na verdade a gente está indo fazer
perguntas
a gente não sabe direito o que a gente
está esperando e foi muito mágica essa
possibilidade da gente perguntar e
caminhar e aprender fazendo ea
possibilidade da gente às vezes por um
caminho e aí pela upa aqui é mais
complicado qual é a solução eu acho que
o ser humano ele tem um recurso incrível
que a criatividade ea criatividade ela
muitas vezes surge da necessidade
então esse projeto de maneira alguma ele
foi a zona de conforto teve vários
momentos que tiveram um conforto que a
gente não tinha solução mas elas foram
surgindo conforme a gente foi se
movimentando na mesma forma que o
projeto proporcionou essa aprendizagem
pra mim eu senti muito dessa
aprendizagem nas escolas cada uma dessas
iniciativas ea gente deixou de falar
escola para falar espaços de
aprendizagem porque a gente entendeu
inclusive que muitas vezes o espaço
aberto a vida como um todo uma grande
plataforma de aprendizagem possibilita
com que a gente se desenvolva e faça com
que a gente vai ser prof aprofundando e
se aproximando daquilo que faz sentido
para a gente
e assim eu espero verdadeiramente que a
educação daqui pra frente que uma
educação inovadora inspiradora é aquela
que faça com que cada um de nós seja
melhor forma de nós mesmo que faça com
que a gente consiga buscar aquilo que
faz sentido e que todo dia você aqui
ora sabendo que tem um porquê de acordar
e que tem um porquê de se realizar
eu aprendi um pouco disso ao longo dessa
jornada
e eu acabei me encontrando com uma moça
que colocou uma frase que eu achei linda
que foi a educação ela despertou os meus
sonhos dormentes e agora eu sei que eu
posso sonhar mais e isso foi uma das
melhores coisas de poder escutar aqui
você vai encontrando pessoas que ressoam
com seus sonhos que ressoam com as suas
com seus valores e às suas realizações e
assim todo mundo vai construindo junto
muito obrigada